foreign
by myself singing 99 bottles of milk on
the wall to this child that just can't
deal Ally beer beer
[Music]
Merry Christmas
[Music]
that didn't even sound right at all man
why are you listening to the show you
should be with your families or making
gingerbread houses or something or if
you like the rest of us you were huddled
in a closet
desperately avoiding all of your family
or you're driving
a weirdly like side eyeing
your romantic spouse or partner or your
got headphones in so you can't hear your
kids because oh gosh kids and so welcome
to the greatest mental health and
marriage podcast ever recorded
this special holiday edition just a few
days before Christmas or if you're
traveling you don't even listen to this
and you're just picking it up on
Christmas and you're for sure you're
you've just climbed into the trunk of a
car because it's the only safe quiet
place you can find hey we're glad that
you're here we got a special Christmas
show for you uh we're gonna take a few
calls and we'll do something cool at the
end here but we're so grateful that
you're here if you want to be on the
show in the new year
give me a buzz
1-844-693-3291 and over the next few
weeks we're gonna be talking about New
Year's resolutions and what we're going
to do moving into the new year and I'm
super hyped but I'm glad you're with us
today I do in all seriousness hope
you're having a great Christmas holiday
and for those of you who are missing
somebody that you love uh I'm with you
and
um I'm gonna choose to miss them with
sadness in my heart but a smile on my
face because I'm gonna remember the good
stuff that I'm missing as well so uh
let's get right to the phones after 15
minutes of me running my mouth then
we'll get right to the phones let's go
to Ali in Nashville what's up Ali
hey Dr John it's so awesome to talk to
you it's awesome to talk to you you're
in my neighborhood you should just come
on down what's up
I actually drove by Ramsey Solutions
just the other day I was like oh it was
Saturday so you weren't there I wasn't
there actually I lived here um my wife
kicked me out and so I lived just
kidding she didn't thanks so so what's
up
okay well I'm sorry I'm super nervous
I'm gonna try to be direct but I I like
to talk so I'm just just cut me off
whenever I like to talk too so let's do
it let's do it okay so I'm struggling I
listen to your show a lot and I I really
appreciate all that you do I try to
apply what you say to my life and and
this is just one area where I'm just
struggling with you talk about you know
pictures that we have and I had this
picture of what I thought that Christmas
was going to look like with a new baby
and my family and it doesn't feel like
that's actually the reality of what my
picture was and I'm kind of grieving
that
um and I don't really know how to
process it I don't really know
what the right thing for me to do if I
should lean into family even though it's
really difficult with a baby or if I
should kind of pull out a little bit and
my husband and I kind of do our own
tradition I'm just kind of struggling
what what do you what did you think it
was going to look like and what is
reality
okay well I
[Music]
have very over stimulated and I have a
big family and so we've had some family
gatherings with him we just recently did
Thanksgiving and it was not at all like
I love Thanksgiving and being with my
family but I spent the entire
Thanksgiving like in another room trying
to soothe him because it was just too
much for him
um you know and I guess I imagined
everybody passes the baby around and
it's his first Christmas and I'm just
proud mama in the corner and the reality
of it is that I am in a room by myself
singing 99 bottles of milk on the wall
to this child that just can't deal and
Ally beer beer alley milk is not going
to solve your problems milk is not going
to solve your problems
um hey it's like
it's a bummer too did you get did you
get did you get a bunch of advice for
what you should be doing and oh God yeah
Rando uncles and aunts who know
everything and your parents especially I
don't have any children oh yeah exactly
well and your parents thought this would
be when they show off how good of a job
they did at parenting You by how good
well behaved your kid is and um so they
had to make up for your utter failures
to control a four-month-old right what a
mess yeah I know okay so what do you
think is gonna happen in Christmas are
you just picturing a replay of what just
went down at Thanksgiving
yes okay and I don't want to do it
hey let's just feel guilty okay
perfect you're right where you should be
because this is yes if you didn't feel
guilty
you would probably need to go see
somebody immediately
it something would be malfunctioning and
I hate to use mechanized language but
there would be something wrong
you have to say I mean you you're
exhausted number one your marriage as
good as it can be is still wonky because
it's all messed up and new now right
you're still trying to figure out what
that is it's in Nashville so it's gray
and it's been cold and rainy and then
hot and rainy again and cold
and then you just went through a holiday
where you spent it bouncing a kid up and
down who just pooped and yelled and ate
on repeat and so you missed it all
and then you've had this picture if it's
gonna be like this like this like this
and then your body says hey I'm out
let's don't do that
and I think this might be right for you
in the season and you're gonna feel
super guilty because you want to be a
the kid that makes Mom and Dad happy
you've probably been a peacemaker for a
lot of your life you want to bring your
kid around and not miss Christmas and
yada you want all these things but
there's a reality to it or maybe there's
a middle ground that's going to be maybe
we're gonna lean into it for a little
bit but not all the way so I I I really
respect the fact that you're listening
to your body right now and you're saying
out loud I don't want this I don't want
to experience again what I just went
through good for you that's that's huge
and that you're feeling guilty yes
you're right where you should be so
where does your family live where are
they doing Christmas
oh they're they're close most of them
live in either Murfreesboro or
Shelbyville and Christmas is going to be
at Shelby in Shelbyville okay so for
those of you listening it's it's within
an hour right or an hour hour and a half
it's around
um is there a possibility that you say
we're gonna go for three hours and head
out
yeah I guess I'm thinking okay an hour
drive there and then three hours
room with a upset child for maybe 15
minutes of FaceTime with everybody and
then an hour back I guess I'm just kind
of already with I don't want to say
resenting but I think I'm already
resenting that
are you resenting that or are you
resenting the fact that you're going to
go all the way out there and your baby's
not going to cooperate
yes that's a different proposition
because then you're not resenting them
you're just resist you're just I don't
even think you're at resentment now
resentment is when you hope somebody
else's life isn't going well I don't
think I think you're just frustrated and
sad and mad and frustrated and sad and
mad and frustrated on Loop and that's
super okay because life with a four
month old is super frustrating I
remember thinking my four-year-old was
gonna be like we're gonna be playing
Spades we're gonna be playing cards like
playing Texas Hold'em and it was just
like a lump that craft all the time and
I I just remember being frustrated so
much more than I thought I was going to
be and I had to say the obligatory oh
it's the best thing ever it was hard and
I didn't know who my wife was oh that
was hard
um I think you'll regret not going for a
few minutes now if you were telling me
you're gonna travel four hours or six
hours or eight hours I think it would be
super fair to say hey this year just not
a good year
I think we've got a newborn we're still
figuring things out
um this won't be a good year we'll
FaceTime everybody and we'll you know
we'll do all that but we're I'm
exhausted and this isn't a good year
being within an hour I think long term
um like a six hour half day
yes is gonna be a pain but I think that
um you'll regret not doing that that's
just my that's just my opinion there's a
little bit more than that there's
actually like three or four family
gatherings over the span of Christmas
Eve and Christmas let's reframe that
let's reframe
different groups of your family are
going to get together for multiple times
you're not yes
and that's I guess where I'm at is the
is the big group is getting together and
I feel like that's the time that's
I don't know because I feel like that's
going to be the most not
in tune with my family that I'm gonna be
I feel like the smaller groups with my
parents and then my mom and my little
sister separately and then my
grandparents those are those I'm looking
forward to because
I feel like there's less people there's
less stimuli and you can go to that
there's more understanding then go to
those
here's a beautiful thing about the
moment you're in you get to choose
I just don't want to make the wrong
choice or have people feel like because
I opted out of one family gathering one
time that they're gonna opt out
in the future you can't control well you
might opt out in the future
you can't control how other adults
respond to your boundaries
you can't you can't control how other
adults respond to what you need in a
particular season
and right now you've got a four month
old who doesn't do well in big groups
and you've got people without kids who
love giving information about how what
you should be doing to raise this kid
and it's not a good environment so cool
we're gonna take a year
I think in 20 years you're going to wish
you had that photo but you're also going
to have multiple opportunities for small
group get togethers like you just
mentioned and maybe those are going to
be better situated and since you're
close you can make that call
um that sounds great
here's the here's the Neta here
I don't think there's a wrong
there's only a wrong if you allow it to
be wrong in 10 years you might really
wish
I just gone
but then you can remember back and say
yeah it wasn't going to happen that year
I'm all good I made the best decision
for me at the time
yeah does that make sense
it does and this is the worst part of
having kids it's the worst it's the
worst it's just it's sad because like
I I don't blame my kid because he's a
baby he's a baby I just didn't imagine
it was going to be like this but you're
blaming yourself
don't do that
yeah don't blame you
you're a new mom
yeah and you're practicing this and
missing the big shindig is is gonna
cause all oh my gosh great guys I'm
gonna see you like in two days
yeah it's not gonna happen on this one
what's your husband think
he pretty much 100 agrees with you he's
very well we're just going to tell him
we're not coming and I'm like no we have
to fight no actually you you married a
hero I need a hero
you married him you married no he's the
best he hey he's he sounds like he's the
best just off this one thing
um yeah here's what I want you to do
um couple of things I want you to be
very specific about here's what I wanted
okay and if you're a real gangster
you'll you'll take half an hour when
your baby's asleep and you're not dozing
off and you'll write this down here's
what I wanted
and I want you to write it down be very
very specific and then I want you to
write down why you wanted it this way
did you want to do it because you wanted
to show off baby because you wanted
pictures for 20 years from now because
you wanted to prove to everybody see I
made it or I did like be very specific
why did you actually care about this
because this is just the way this is
supposed to be my mom wanted me there
like be very specific about it and then
be super clear about what is
what is right with no judgments
just this is the reality we just did
Thanksgiving baby gets overstimulated we
have a lot of loud wild family it's just
not going to be a good situation for any
of us it took four days to get baby
resettled again and back in routine it's
just not a fight I want to have during
the holidays not our first Christmas
together with our new family that that's
starting off
and I want you to be very clear on this
one thing I'm going to put in front of
you you get to decide
to choose Joy or misery moving forward
you don't think that there's any like
maybe this is irrational because your
little nephew didn't come to Christmas
we don't have as close of a connection
with him as we could ABS I mean that's
b-a-n-n-a-s for four months for a four
month old here's here's what the
greatest gift you can give to a four
month old
is a mom who's got peace
three
and baby is going to take a lot of cues
from Mom
not all but a lot
so a mom who's not stressed
will generally speaking directionally
speaking have a baby who's less stressed
a mom who is at peace who is having Joy
will have a baby who's not always
there's colicky babies and I was
peaceful in my baby ah well
we could probably go down a rabbit hole
in that one but
I would try to create
a non-anxious Christmas let's try that
we're going to create a non-anxious
Christmas one where you take care of
your body
um you're gonna have movement you're
gonna sleep when you can which I know is
a disaster with a four month old you're
gonna eat and you're gonna enjoy meals
but you're not gonna go down like
would do it to your body what I did to
mine this past week on a trip to Texas I
ate myself
blind and
um you're gonna take care of your body
you're going to make sure you stay
connected with your husband you're gonna
have boundaries you're gonna do the next
right thing and if you wake up that
morning and your baby's in a great mood
you think I think we can pull this off
take your baby just show up don't be so
surprised
and if you wake up that morning and
you're like not happening don't go just
don't go
just don't go and if you feel sad
feel sad feel sad it's okay to feel sad
then look for beauty
look for things that make you laugh talk
through a plan with your husband about
what here's what I need you to do when I
start getting sad
my guess is if you choose to build a
non-anxious Christmas you can figure out
the path that way the path to a
non-anxious Christmas
that is going to create for a great
Christmas Memories and a really really
happy baby we'll be right back
hey what's up deloney here I know I know
it's the holidays you're super busy and
between all the decorating Christmas
trees and Christmas parties and your
friends drinking too much eggnog family
visits so many family visits it's so
easy to skimp on sleep don't fall into
that trap my friends you've got to take
care of yourself and your mental health
during the holidays and that means
prioritizing sleep sleep is one of the
best things you can do for your mental
health any time of year but especially
right now and for me getting deep
restorative sleep starts with a good
mattress and that's why my family sleeps
on dream Cloud mattresses and right now
dream Club is running an unbelievable
offer exclusively for my listeners get
25 off any mattress 599 dollars in
accessories that's pillows a mattress
protector and luxury sheets plus an
additional 50 cash discount when you use
promo code deloni so go to
dreamcloudsleep.com
or dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo
code deloni to get your new mattress
today
all right we are back let's go to Tulsa
Oklahoma and talk to Julia gulia what's
up Julia
hello Dr John thank you so much for
taking my call thank you for calling in
what's happening
well I'm a little nervous but I I think
some of it's because I'm talking to you
but most of it's because
I've been struggling for many many years
about how to make
or the right decision for my for my 17
year old
um and specifically right now the issues
that's come up is that I'm trying to
decide if I should make him go with us
to North Dakota for Christmas or if I
should allow him to stay
in Oklahoma which is with a friend and I
think everything is just come to this
point where I've had so many years of
advice and and decisiveness
and I'm just exhausted and for whatever
reason this was the icing and I reached
out because I I trust your opinion as a
third party I appreciate that
um
yeah
why have you felt indecisive over the
years
um
assuming
um a mom or a dad that was really
involved I I had nannies for the most
part and I was the oldest child and I
took care of my siblings as well
um also I
so I didn't really have a good parental
role model I put a lot of thought into
this
um but but also a lot of the input I've
received over the years
the times I thought I was doing right
and really killing it you know I've had
infants from other people that they were
not in agreement with what I was doing
how I was doing things who are these
people um and why do they get
um my husband oh I guess there's that
are y'all still married
oh yeah no we're married
um okay so give me an example of a thing
you thought you were killing it and he
was like well you're doing this wrong
well I so I had my 17 year old I wasn't
married and I had him um right before I
was about to go to medical school
and I postponed medical school for two
years and ended up going through it by
myself with my son okay
um and also through residency
um a lot of that time obviously I was
just in survival mode and
um
you know studying very very early in the
morning so I wouldn't disrupt our free
time together
um obviously there were sacrifices so so
you are you are the top one percent of
one percent of one percent of gangsters
I appreciate that thank you like I can't
think of any reason on planet Earth why
you would be calling me for my my advice
like I you a person I would reach out to
because you not only have the academic
knowledge you've lived it and you
haven't lived it like theoretically or
like had a conversation
you did five to six years of
45 minutes of sleep at night to preserve
a relationship with the little boy and
at the same time we'll learn how to take
care of my little boy when I come
stumbling into the ER in the middle of
the night
um right see what I'm saying yeah like
there is there is very few people on the
planet who should be challenging like
well you're doing that one raw and God
bless your husband like he's not on the
phone so I can talk bad about him but
wow I mean wow so yeah so sorry for
interrupting I just I mean I don't get
to talk to just gangsters every day and
you definitely won
that that means a lot to me thank you I
sometimes forget all that I've um all
that I've done I thank you to force with
the trees
um uh so I because of all of that you
know I really just took a lot of things
on myself like I would just clean the
house right I wouldn't make him take the
trash out I would just get it done
because my time was so limited
and I didn't you know um really teach
him all of those things and hold him
responsible for
for chores and um but he was always
really good at school he was a great kid
always got good remarks from parents and
teachers as far as his character and so
I really didn't focus on that a whole
lot and that's become um a significant
point of contention
now that he's older my husband was
raised totally the opposite
um
um and
I'm
and I just don't know how hard to come
down on him as far as
responsibilities and this whole question
about Christmas kind of plays into that
like how hard do I press about making
him do things and and you know do I even
care like even my own opinion of how
important things are is often challenged
I often second guess myself and I also
have to go to extreme to make a decision
what is your what does your husband do
for a living
um right now he stays at home
um he does a lot of
um
gardening and woodworking
um Gunsmithing he was a paramedic prior
okay
I
um
I'm just going with my gut on this okay
okay
um I'm pretending that you and I you
came to one of the conferences I was
doing and we you and I are just talking
in the hallway okay okay sounds good um
I studied lawyer mental health and I
studied physician and medical
personnel Mental Health
okay and
there's two tracks that happen
relationally and this is a broad
generalization right this isn't
everybody
right right but I think you all are in
desperate need you and your husband of
going to marital counseling right now
because things are about to get sideways
I think
all right I think you've got about it's
been a pretty big issue I think you've
well I think there's it's big this is
symptomatic this is into respect issues
and this is into control and dominance
issues
[Applause]
um
okay I don't want to put it all on him
but somebody has made you feel like your
choices and your decisions and your
thoughts about your relationships
are somehow malfunctioning they're not
right
yeah I don't trust myself that's that
right there
yeah I don't and but that's relational
in nature okay
because something you trusted yourself
enough to go to med school
you judge yourself enough to have this
baby and to figure it out so at one
point you were Unstoppable
yes and over time you have SL that has
slowly eroded away
I agree it's deteriorated a lot right
and I feel like I'm at kind of a bottom
point right and generally speaking again
I'm not making you haven't said this and
so I don't want to speak it into
existence but that comes that erosion
comes from
a significant other
slowly chipping away at self-confidence
at what are you doing it well yeah you
clear your doctor but can you can't even
do this and over time it just becomes
this you spin in a Tighter and Tighter
Circle
yes to something as simple as dude
you're coming to Christmas
becomes a paralyzing decision
is it this is ringing a bell right
it's been absolutely paralyzing that's
why I reached out I didn't know what
else to do I mean okay yeah how long
have you been married
um almost six years you all need to go
see somebody like ASAP
okay this is one that you're you have 17
year old you have other kids
yes we have
we have there are five and four gosh are
you exhausted and they're awesome are
you exhausted I'm exhausted I'm
exhausted
the great life I mean but I am excited
I am spent Dr John yeah I'm exhausted
um here's here's how I know that
because you could
diagnose me with a I could be having a
heart attack right now and you could let
me know that
but when it comes to relational
decisions in your life
there's there's a block there's a pause
and here's what I would think say about
your kid
um number one I wouldn't blame him for a
second for not wanting to go to
North Dakota whatever crap does he have
something does he have like is he in
love with somebody
yes he just got a brand new girlfriend
of course so it's it's he's gonna just
want to be with girlfriend and I just
want to stay home dude he's he's exactly
he's every 17 year old the planet
17 year olds have parents and and why we
as a society we all got our heads in we
can't just we can't decide whether
something's an illness or not we can't
decide whether to do chemotherapy or
essential oils we can't decide crap but
we've all decided
you know what let's don't let them buy
uh cigarettes or lottery tickets till
they're 18. are we good with that and
then we're like hey you know what let's
just go ahead and pump the brakes a
little more let's don't let them buy
guns or or beer until 21 are we all good
with that everyone's like yeah for sure
right we've all agreed on that
and so that's right I say this with all
due respect your 17 year old doesn't get
a vote
right he does get input and I'll explain
what I mean by that but he doesn't get a
vote
so the two questions I'll ask you is
question number one is
are you using him as a fantasy to prop
up some sort of Christmas picture you
have
oh no this is actually not I don't want
to go either but I'm doing it so is he
is
so are you going to hang out with your
ex with your ex or his dad his
biological father
oh it's actually my head I had parents
and their family they're very sweet and
kind I just don't like
call Santa coming to our house you know
and not someone else's house but they're
the oldest grandparents that we have and
I feel like it's important we don't get
to see them very often so I feel like
it's important if we have a chance to go
okay I feel like that's ultimately a
priority so so number one your kid is
going to absorb every
every every I'm trying to think of the
right way every PSI every square inch
that you don't want to go like Vibe yes
every every energetic wave you put into
the universe okay okay also going to
absorb all the relational tension
between you and your husband right now
yes I've noticed that our little kids do
too when there are issues yeah and
unless your husband is a miracle worker
there is a distinct difference between
quote unquote his kids and your kid
and your 17 year old absorbs that too
right and then you tell me I've got to
go to freaking North Dakota in December
and my girlfriend is here and you know
what she wants to do just make out all
of Christmas but no mom's got a dress so
yeah I mean all that is there and so
here's when I say he doesn't get a vote
he's going okay and and I'm just here's
what I'm telling you I'm just telling
you what I would do if it was my kid
okay
but
I'll I'll just say exactly what just
happened I made my 12 year old he's not
17 but he's almost 13. he had to come
with us
um on a on a Texas trip
to see family and I built in a half day
we had a long hunt with an old old
friend of mine a former roommate of mine
a guy that I owe almost all my life to
um I hadn't seen him in a while and so
we went out and did some fun stuff my
father-in-law took us fishing one
afternoon and one day I just kicked a
soccer ball with him forever
right so I built in time like hey while
we're here give me a couple of things
that you want to make sure you do and I
was intentional about planning some
things that I knew he would love and we
made some memories on this past trip
that he'll he'll he'll tell a couple of
these stories at my funeral
right
right I love that there's a he's really
into nutrition right now and working out
yes we're members of the YMCA there's
one where we're going I should call
ahead of time and just maybe set up like
a some time where we can go work out and
do those kinds of things if you said hey
every morning we're doing the workouts
but I want you to design them
uh and I'll do whatever work out you you
challenge your mom bring it bring it oh
no right okay I can do that yeah but
give him some like and then hey pick you
and I are gonna go on a date we're gonna
have to get away from this madness at
some point so you and I are going on a
date I want to know where you want to go
okay yeah and does that make sense it
absolutely does okay yeah so simple but
you know things you don't think of well
here's the thing it's it's
um when it comes to the the
responsibility side
the I I want to look at those as skills
okay and you clearly gave him some great
character skills you gave him some great
he will live with that work ethic your
work ethic is very similar to my mom's
and I
um I'm a result of that I can outwork
anybody because my mom laid a path for
me and I can never say the words I can't
because I I watched that's right my
gangster mom my family is hopefully she
my mom's just let us know she's teaching
at Oxford and she's 72 this summer like
so she laid a foundation for us it's
like there is no excuses at 71 I can't
be like I'm tired I want no grandma was
flying across the world to go teach it
so you you've given your son that same
thing here's what you didn't give him
um hey you know how good it feels when
you climb into a maid bed that begins at
6 45 in the morning when you get up so
it's just it's a set of skills and when
new dad goes to war and calls him lazy
or just not being a man or not character
that's dumb because he's going to war
over false pretenses your son does need
to learn some skills and by the way at
17
who got a whole new family at age 11
right yes I'd pick my battles
I'd pick my battles I remember going to
college and my mom over Christmas saying
hey uh how often do you wash your sheets
and I remember thinking
that never occurred to me it never even
entered my mind right and right then all
of a sudden I had roommates and friends
who taught me about hygiene and then I
got married and then I'm my life is
turned out fine
see what I'm saying like it's don't
major in the miners is what I'm saying
you've got a great kid sounds like he
knows how to work hard
um and he loves his mom and he's gonna
put in the time and the effort
um I would
I would re-engage with husband about how
he talks to you about how dumb you are
and how you don't know what you're
talking about
it bothers me Julia just does
tell me if I'm wrong
no I feel
I feel still tired
um and after I'm starting to question
other parts of my life too well how can
I be possible possible to be doing this
right yes career yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes
yeah and maybe that comes from other
places but in my experience it it's
usually rather singular in origin
okay
and I can re-engage yeah well I think
re-engage but I think
here's the way I would approach it
I want a home that when I get done being
a doctor
I can't wait to come home and here's
what that looks like
okay and by the way
I'm not stupid
and so we're not gonna engage in my
inside my house
in a way that I don't allow my
colleagues to talk to me at the office
I'm not dumb
we may disagree may have different
pictures of what we want things to look
like but you're not gonna call me stupid
you're not going to send me into another
room wondering if I'm insane
because I'm not
you see what I'm saying yeah yeah I feel
like bounced like ideas Just Bounce
inside my head like a ping pong you know
they just I just can't figure out what's
what's right and what's not yes it just
feels like the gas lights are burning
bright my sister and that at some point
if you take on a great gas lighter in
that way it just ends up in big
loop-de-loops the easier way to go about
it is to say here's the life I'm looking
for
and here's the life I want to build
together with you and here's what I need
that to look like and if you're going to
stay at home and be a stay-at-home
whoever great that's awesome here's what
I need
and you haven't asked that question in a
long long time have you
probably not that way no not said this
is what I want it to look like this is
what I need as far as that goes
um do you think how much input should he
have with with discipline I mean he's 17
and so I feel like
I'm just kind of barely hanging on until
he goes to college and really trying to
focus on relationship I don't really
know I mean
what kind of what what does he need
disciplining for
he thinks I need to withhold
allowance and withhold access to a car
and take away his phone things like that
for not doing chores not doing what he's
supposed to do or not doing the chores
the right way
um
I'm just happy to see him when he gets
home he has such a he can have a hectic
schedule and
um he's making good grades you know he
goes to kind of an intense school I just
I don't know how much input
responsibility to give him on that side
I don't know discipline's important here
here's what that's a whole this is a
whole other call and I'd love to walk
through it with you because I'm
definitely some strong opinions but let
me let me tell you this
okay
for some for some reason and I'd love
for you to sit down with counselor and
walk through this right you no longer
trust your gut
no I don't and you should
okay because you're worth trusting
okay okay and
yes he should have accountability and
yes he there should be consequences and
discipline all those things are
important
and
um
he's gonna step back and rightfully so
say Mom what do you want from me
I got straight A's
I'm in a really hard high school is he
working
he just got his first job he starts
today and he was doing um football and
wrestling so he was really busy oh so he
is a gangster of discipline right
um uh he's very very disciplined he's
very hard working he's understands what
competition and uh doing the right thing
looks like and doing the hard thing
looks like he knows how to get hit in
the mouth and get back up he knows all
these things he's got a job he's got a
girlfriend
okay dude he didn't pick up his laundry
are we gonna go to war over that right
now right right and so
I like on a lot of those issues the
social consequences he's gonna have
friends and be like dude you smell like
a dead animal or his sweet new
girlfriend's gonna lean over and be like
wow you know what you could have done
this week bathe that would have been
awesome right and there's just some
natural consequences to this
unless there is two Alphas in a
household trying to see who can pee up a
tree the highest
right and that it gets obnoxious
yes I agree you see what I'm saying yes
and God help him dude if if not making
his bed is gonna
I got his life will I learned when I got
married I love my life is better when I
get into a made bed in the evening it's
worth the 30 seconds when I wake up and
in fact it makes my whole day better
I I I seem to do just fine I did just
fine
I'd much rather see him get to wrestling
practice on time and really do well
there and do well at work and do well as
a person of character and integrity he
tells the truth and he respects his mom
uh mom here's what I want to see you do
I want to see you start to take him on a
date once a week if you can at all
manage it
leave your husband with the other two
and take him on a date once a week y'all
go to some crummy Diner in your town and
y'all go hang out and just be together
talk about the future talk about the
things you've done wrong talk about the
funny stories about your life he doesn't
even know about the time you went out
and you you know you tried some stuff
that concert you went to that went I
went start talking about it because you
got about 18 months and he's on his own
he's out of here if that
[Music]
don't let things unsaid
but this is all about relationship and
your initial question if he's my 17 year
old he's coming with us but he's going
to have some input on what that trip
looks like
and man I am going to lead the way with
a positive attitude with laughter and
when I get frustrated I'm gonna speak it
out hey guys I'm frustrated not at y'all
I'm choosing to be frustrated over the
travel situations or the fact that it's
50 below or whatever it's going to be
wherever we're in North Dakota all those
things
lead the way and you and your husband
you don't need to go talk to somebody
ASAP we'll be right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless home buyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process you need
folks like my friends at Churchill
Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay trusted
provider that's been helping people with
their home mortgages for decades and
their home buyer Edge program will help
you skip a bunch of the stress here's
how it works apply to become a Churchill
certified home buyer and cap your
interest rate for 90 days then you'll
get a five thousand dollar seller
guarantee to help your offer stand out
so go ahead take a deep breath because
Churchill has your back check them out
at churchillmortgage.com
deloni and get the home buyer Edge today
this is a paid advertisement in MLS ID
1591 nmls consumeraccess.org Equal
Housing lender 1749 Mallory Lane Suite
100 Brentwood Tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only not
available in all states or locations
all right we are back and if you're
watching this
you can clearly see I've lost control of
my own show
and now I'm wearing a Christmas hat oh
here we go
[Music]
it's a Christmas trap
Xmas hip hop I love it dude well done
thank you
oh man okay so before we go down the
Christmas Rabbit Hole a quick moment of
silence here
um Kelly is out and her mom passed away
after a long
um
uh
really incredible battle with
Alzheimer's and she passed away her
name's Roberta and um so Kelly is out
home taking care of that and just wanted
Kelly know that we love you and that we
miss you and that uh you're in our
thoughts in prayers and she had a lot of
plans for this holiday show and Jenna
has taken the reins
and the Rudolph the whatever
the Reindeer reindeer yes reindeer
antlers I'm in deer hunting a lot so it
just it makes me please don't shoot me
oh come on
come on ridiculous ah but not really I
get it I won't I won't I won't unless
you go running across I'm just kidding
so um
Kelly we love you and we'll be thinking
about you and praying about you and your
family
um all right so
Kelly asked me to read a book
Christmas Story and so I brought what is
one of my House's favorite Christmas
books by Mike Reese and by
my wife is a children's literature
person
um and but I share this with her David
catrow one of our favorite illustrators
the book is called Merry on Christmas
it's about a family who has Christmas
every day of the year and it's such a
burden and they get one day off a year I
love this book and I was gonna read it
but then fun ruiner.com
net.org here
and I won't name their name Chris said
that we have to have copyright to
everything so we can't read the book so
go buy it I want to support mic I have
no relationship to this dude but I think
this book's fantastic and the
illustrations are incredible by David
um so we are going to the public domain
and we're going to read with some
commentary
a few people's favorite Christmas Story
it was the night before Christmas
[Music]
it was the night before Christmas went
all through the house
not a creature was stirring not even a
mouse
the stockings were hung by the chimney
with care and tape in hopes that Saint
Nicholas
soon would be there not eating the
grapes
bad rhyming the children were all snug
in their beds nestled all snug in their
beds while visions of
sugar plums
and cigarettes depending on what kind of
kid you're raising danced in their heads
and mama and her kerchief
mama
is that I use all you sleep in is it
kerchief
um in my eye in my cap man this this
story got a little bit
about whoa
had settled down for a long winter's nap
they've been drinking
when out on the lawn there arose such a
clatter
was it somebody doing drugs and another
Mad Hatter no I sprang from the bed to
see what was the matter
evidently had time to get dressed
because he was previously only wearing a
cap
away to the window I flew like a flash I
put on some clothes so no one would see
my tore open the shutters and threw up
the sash
the moon on the breast of the new fallen
snow gave the luster of the midday to
objects below
so it's like a freshman in college
trying to write a research paper like
there's so much easier ways to say this
when what to my wondering eyes should
appear
drugs no but a miniature sleigh an eight
tiny reindeer
had I done too much shrooms I asked
myself
slick with a little old driver so Lively
and quick no I knew in a moment it must
be Saint Nick
more rapid than Eagles his courser as
they came and he whistled and shouted
and called him by name
now Dasher now dancer now Prancer and
Vixen
on comment on Cupid on donder and
Blitzen
to the top of the porch to the top of
the wall
now dash away Dash away Dash away all
at which point all the reindeer look at
each other and like what the crap is he
talking about like what why is he just
yelling our names and telling us to
score the porches and walls what what is
happening
but they're just deer they just do what
they're told you know
as dry leaves before the wild hurricane
fly now we're getting into weather issue
this whole thing is just getting off the
rails when they meet with an obstacle
mount to the sky
for those of you who run into obstacle
mounts in the sky you've done far too
much drugs that day it's time to stop
it's time to stop go to bed reset
so up to the Housetop the coursers they
flew with the sleigh full of toys in
Saint Nicholas too
and then in a twinkling I heard on the
roof
[Laughter]
one of the reindeer had taken it just
kidding the Prancing and pawing of each
little hoof
as I drew in my head and was turning
around down the chimney St Nicholas came
with a bound
and he was quite round
and he made a sound like a basset hound
with a frown he was dressed all in fur
dude that's what I'm talking about
what's up ladies
from his head to his foot and his
clothes were all tarnished with ashes
and soot
I think that's because he was rolling a
little 20 twin twin but that's just me
a bundle of toys he had flung on his
back and he looked like a peddler just
opening his pack
here's just a random bunch of pictures
and the dog wagging his tail
way to go here Fido
terrible guard dog
his eyes how they twinkled his dimples
how merry his cheeks were like roses his
nose like a cherry
can we just stop this whole story is
madness it's just some Madness look at
this photo this guy
this just rolled up on somebody's
recliner with feet out just chilling
arms back
he's doped up the dog kicked his feet
off he's just chilling and I guess he
lit the fire back that makes sense
his droll little mouth was drawn up like
a bow and the beard on his chin was as
white as the snow
the stump of a pipe he held in his teeth
he's smoking inside great neighbor very
cool
and the smoke had encircled his head
like a wreath
puff puff give
he had a broad face in a round little
belly
That Shook like when he laughed like a
bowl full of jelly now this book's just
getting mean it's just mean he needs to
call into the show people talking bad
about him
he was chubby and plump a right Jolly
Old elf and I laughed when I saw him in
spite of myself
can you imagine somebody breaking it
into your house and then
you see them you're not scared you just
laugh at their physical appearance I
think the author of this book should
call the show because he needs an
attitude adjustment he's rude he's mean
it's me a wink of his eye and a Twist of
his head
I worry to myself am I soon to be dead
soon gave me to know I had nothing to
dread
he spoke not a word but went straight to
his work and filled all of the stockings
then turned with a jerk maybe it's meth
and not smoking
and laying his finger up inside of his
nose a side of his nose and giving a nod
up the chimney he rose
he sprang to his sleigh to his team gave
a whistle
and he away they all flew like the down
of a Thistle and let's be honest we all
know how the down of a thistle flies
[Music]
[Applause]
this is why this this right here why are
our kids so anxious because of this
[Music]
he drove out of sight
I got all your crap Merry Christmas to
all and to all
a good night
[Music]
Merry Christmas to you all everybody I
love you
[Applause]
hang on for one second we're gonna go to
break when we get back we'll do the song
of the day that will send you off into
Christmas for you for people who are
still listening we'll be right back
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible in each person's situation is
unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
hey in all seriousness I hope you have a
great Christmas
um great holiday season
um
hope that you were able to grieve those
that aren't at the table with you this
year and I hope you are able to choose
guilt over resentment for those of you
who have imposed new boundaries this
year
and hope that you're able to look around
and not look at what's missing or what
you don't have but focus on finding
Beauty and being grateful for the things
that you do have
and finding the mess in the middle and
if you have a couple nights where you
you overdo it good for you be safe and
be smart and if uh you have a couple of
nights where you choose you know what
I'm not gonna have 17 cookies I'm gonna
have one
God Bless you that's impressive and uh
we we'd be proud of you song of the day
is my favorite uh Christmas song from my
childhood
I used to rock it onto the break of dawn
when I was a kid I didn't know Gene
Autry wrote it it may not have you maybe
just saying it but
song goes like this
Up on the Rooftop reindeer pause
out jumps good old Santa Claus down
through the chimney with lots of toys
all for the little ones Christmas joys
who wouldn't go ho ho ho who wouldn't go
up on the route rooftop click click
click
down through the chimney good Saint Nick
merry Christmas everybody stay in school
don't do drugs talk to you soon